[Musique]
aujourd'hui à l'émission les insectes
piqueurs nuisent aux activités en plein
air
pour s'en débarrasser il existe un
produit le bti mythe quels sont les
impacts sur la biodiversité
quand on tue les petits animaux à la
base de la chaîne alimentaire
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte
pour certains il l'était peut sembler
encore loin mais rappelez vous à quel
point il est désagréable de se faire
piquer par des moustiques des mouches
noires pour régler le problème
un produit qui tue les larves de ces
insectes piqueurs a été inventé le bti
un produit largement utilisée ici et
ailleurs dans le monde mais est il
vraiment inoffensif
depuis la nuit des temps les humains et
les insectes piqueurs entretiennent une
relation difficile lors des activités de
plein air l'été
les insectes sont une véritable nuisance
ils peuvent être aussi des vecteurs de
maladies mortelles
le moustique est l'organisme le plus
dangereux au monde
chaque minute une personne vers la vie
surtout des enfants qui meurent du
paludisme au sud du sahara
pour combattre les moustiques des
insecticides chimiques ont été utilisés
pendant des décennies
et ils ont causé des dommages importants
à l'environnement depuis on s'est tourné
vers un insecticide biologique miracle
le becquet mais à vouloir éliminer les
insectes piqueurs
sommes-nous en train de créer un autre
problème c'est que les insectes sont
aussi indispensables à la santé de nos
écosystèmes et leur déclin dramatique à
l'échelle planétaire laisse présager le
pire
c'est dans ce contexte que l'utilisation
du bti dans la lutte aux insectes
piqueurs et remise en question chez nous
et à l'étranger
c'était peut-être plus confortable
d'accepter à que le bit ayant peu
d'impact mais là c'est vrai qu'on y va
c'est peut-être pas par exemple il
faudra peut-être vérifier que c'est bien
le cas
c'est logique et très clair si vous vous
débarrasser de cette quantité de
biomasse dans l'écosystème quelque chose
va se produire
je n'ai pas positif
[Musique]
le québec est reconnu pour ses immenses
espaces naturels
avec ses milliers de lacs et de rivières
c'est un véritable paradis pour les
amants de la nature
et c'est aussi une immense pouponnière
pour les 75 espèces de mouches noires et
les 60 espèces de moustiques qui sont
présentes sur le territoire
les mouches noires se reproduise en eaux
vives comme dans les ruisseaux où les
rivières les moustiques quant à eux le
font dans des eaux stagnantes comme les
mares ou encore des contenants
artificiel
dans ces milieux aquatiques leurs yeux
deviennent des larves puis se transforme
graduellement en f
et finalement en adulte
les femelles des mouchoirs et des
moustiques se nourrissent de sang en
piquant les animaux et les humains comme
elle ne meurt pas après leur repas
sanguin les femelles peuvent piquer à
nouveau et propager des maladies graves
comme le virus du nil occidental ou la
malaria dans les régions plus au sud
lorsque ces bestioles sont trop
nombreuses leurs piqûres peuvent devenir
un véritable enfer pour toute une
communauté
pour assurer le confort des citoyens et
garantir les activités touristiques le
bti devient la solution préconisée pour
se débarrasser de ces insectes piqueurs
dans les laurentides la municipalité de
la belle a opté pour l'épandage au betty
en 2019 ici l'utilisation de cet
insecticide est de plus en plus
contestée par les citoyens quand on voit
l'épandage du bti on avait parfois de
tambours de guerre parce que c'est
vraiment l'armée qui débarque donc des
canon pour tuer des uns fait que c'est
vraiment tout un déploiement pour des
petits insectes
hélène gariépy et son conjoint
l'agronome françois labelle font partie
d'un regroupement qui s'opposent au bti
dans leur municipalité
ensemble ils exploitent une ferme
biologique où ils produisent des agneaux
de pâturage
comme ailleurs au pays ils ont constaté
ces dernières années une diminution
importante des oiseaux qui se
nourrissent d'insectes
ce qui est fantastique fait que si je
regarde si le gg 5,9 le prendre en photo
tu vois que c'est un beau jeu puis j'ai
vérifié puis sur la douzaine de venise
et cij a peu près j'ai seulement 2 ni
présentement qui ont des oeufs puis
désormais qu'il sent même pas et habitée
donc je pense qu'il commence à une
réduction de la population de des
rondelles
françois et hélène craignent que la
démoustication au bti élimine une partie
importante du garde manger de plusieurs
espèces d'oiseaux et de batraciens déjà
mal en point
ça change la biodiversité ça qu'on va
s'apercevoir dans 20 à 30 ans
option vraiment problématique et puis on
l'avait oublié parce que ça s'est
installée ces personnes s'en est aperçu
pour avoir l'heure juste sur les enjeux
scientifiques du bdi
nous nous sommes rendus à l'institut de
biologie structurale de grenoble
c'est ici dans ce laboratoire que
travail le chercheur guillaume tétreault
un des spécialistes mondiaux du
fonctionnement du bdi
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs années ils
s'intéressent à cet insecticide qui a
été découvert en israël en 1976 le
métayer déjà qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est un acronyme c'est les initiales de
la bactérie qui produit cette molécule
insecticide qui s'appelle bacillus
thuringiensis israël n 6 et son nom
scientifique l'attend donc les initiales
btig
depuis 40 ans le bti a remplacé
graduellement la plupart des
insecticides chimiques dans plusieurs
pays
le bti et biologique la seule bactérie
qu'il compose vie naturellement dans les
sols en fait ici on voit ça c'est le bti
on voit les bactéries ici donc qui vont
former des débats s'il est donc ici par
an pour na une bactérie qui est intacte
on voit qu'elle est dense dans le bti il
y a trois cristaux ils sont faits de 4
toxines différentes
[Musique]
le bti étaient pendus dans l'eau
stagnante ou courante
là où pendent les moustiques et les
mouches noires l'insecticide ne
s'attaque alors qu aux larves avant
qu'il ne se transforme en adulte
une fois dans l'eau le betty va être
ingérés par la larve lorsque le bio
insecticides arrive dans son intestin
ces cristaux de toxines vont se
dissoudre et perforer les parois
internes du tube digestif
la larve se retrouve alors avec un
intestin transpercer et c'est ce qui va
entraîner sa mort
nous sommes dans la capitale européenne
du bti depuis 40 ans c'est d'ici que
proviennent de nombreuses études sur le
larvicide le biologiste norbert dekker a
travaillé sur plus de 200 publications
scientifiques dans certaines parties du
monde
on m'appelle monsieur bêtises parce que
selon moi le betis un outil formidable
pour résoudre un problème
le professeur baker est devenue une
sommité mondiale dans la lutte
biologique aux insectes piqueurs
[Musique]
le bti est à ses yeux le meilleur
larvicide disponibles dès le début notre
objectif était de protéger la population
contre les moustiques et en même temps
de protéger la nature la biodiversité
nous cherchons l'outil idéal pour
atteindre nos objectifs et le betis est
avéré être une véritable chance ces
études et celles d'autres scientifiques
ont démontré que le betty est un produit
non toxique pour les humains et les
animaux en plus les insectes ne
développerait pas de résistance ou
larvicide le betty et spécifiques facile
à manipuler pas trop compliqués à
produire nous pouvons le stocker
l'utiliser sous forme de granules classe
est dispersée par hélicoptère ou bien
l'impliquer directement au sol
c'est donc un outil parfait fecteau
diminuant ainsi la quantité de
moustiques et l'environnement demeure
intacte
en allemagne le betty est d'abord
utilisé pour contrer la nuisance que
représentent les moustiques comme c'est
le cas sur les berges du rhin
bien qu'ici les codes maladies
transmises par les insectes piqueurs
sont encore peu nombreux contrairement
aux pays tropicaux l'utilisation du bti
est tout de même devenue une question de
santé publique
jusqu'à l'année dernière nous utilisions
le pays pour atténuer la nuisance mais
maintenant nous avons aussi des maladies
transmises par les moustiques comme le
virus du nil occidental et laden
dans mon ski danse il faut donc
contrôler les moustiques pour réduire le
risque de transmission de maladies
cette gestion va améliorer la qualité de
vie et réduire les nuisances mais aussi
protéger la santé des gens malgré la
bonne presse scientifique du bti au fil
des décennies des chercheurs émettent
depuis peu certains d'autres quant à son
utilisation systématique le bti comme il
a été perçu comme un insecticide parfait
quasiment et bien il ya eu peut-être
moins de recherche qui a été fait dans
une recherche d'alternatives en tout cas
de nouveaux produits mais depuis peu les
mises en garde se font pressantes des
études menées en allemagne et en
australie
les montrent que les populations
d'insectes subissent un déclin sans
précédent un peu partout sur la planète
parmi les principales causes de cette
hécatombe
les chercheurs notent une sur
utilisation de pesticides et d'engrais
chimiques
de même qu'une perte d'habitat se
pourrait-il que la lutte aux insectes
piqueurs au moyen du bti fasse aussi
partie du coupable
on a une grosse perte de diversité
tout le monde commence à se questionner
sur l'impact de l'homme sur
l'environnement et donc forcément on va
questionner la place des insecticides et
on va questionner les effets qu'on peut
avoir
[Musique]
en ces temps de pandémie il est
important de le rappeler
oui les insectes piqueurs sont
d'importants vecteurs de diverses
maladies comme la malaria le virus du
nil mais selon l' oms ils ne peuvent pas
transmettre la crevette 19 après la
pause
des recherches qui dérange
[Musique]
nous sommes en camargue dans le sud de
la france l'un des derniers sites
naturels sur le littoral méditerranéen
la région est classée réserve de
biosphère
la camargue est une zone humide de 145
mille hectares abritant une grande
variété d'espèces végétales et animales
on y trouve une quantité importante
d'espèces de moustiques
en 2006 la démoustication expérimental
de la camargue a été documentée par la
biologiste brigitte poulet de
l'organisme tour du valat la québécoise
qui est chercheur en écologie des
oiseaux travaille depuis plus de 20 ans
à cet institut de recherche pour la
conservation des zones humides avec le
résultat de ces études
elle est devenue une des premières
scientifique a sonné l'alarmé sur
l'utilisation du betty on m'a demandé de
fournir des études sur l'impact du bti
donc j'ai pensé travailler sur les
impacts à travers la chaîne alimentaire
dans multijeux betty souvent dans des
milieux naturels qui sont riches en
biodiversité les milieux aquatiques
c'est les milieux les plus riches qu'on
a sur la planète
donc si on réduit l'abondance des
moustiques est ce que les animaux qui
les utilisent comme nourriture vont être
affectés ou pas contrairement à ce qui
semblait faire consensus dans la
communauté scientifique
la démoustication au bti ne tuerait pas
que les larves de moustiques et de
mouches noires selon brigitte poulin
le problème en fait c'est que ça va
affecter également les chironomes qui
sont les petits cousins des moustiques
les chironomes sont des insectes non
piqueur qu'on reconnaît facilement à
leurs vols groupés
au stade larvaire les chironomes vivent
dans la boue et la vase au fond des
plans d'eau et constitue une partie
importante de la nourriture disponible
dans les milieux aquatiques la
diminution des chironomes affecterait
aussi plusieurs prédateurs
il y aurait un effet négatif sur
l'ensemble de la chaîne alimentaire
en termes d'impact dont par exemple on a
deux fois moins de libellule en termes
d'espèces et d'individus sur dans les
milieux traités au bti par rapport à
ceux qui ne sont pas comme pour
supprimer le droit qui est appréciée il
va y avoir des problèmes carnassiers
michel son alternative c'est parce
qu'elles sont pas optimales
donc dans le cas de l'étude des
hirondelles qu'on a fait en camargue on
a constaté qu'elle perdait un tiers des
petits en fait toni qui mouraient de
faim
suite à l'absence des ressources
alimentaires adéquat on a vu que les
oiseaux se tourner vers des fourmis
volantes mais qu'il y avait encore
beaucoup plus difficile à digérer
et quand il donné les fruits ou au petit
oisillon ben en fait ça passe à tout
droit ce n'est pas digéré dans cet
accord rien leur donner et dans la niche
et ben y en a un qui va être un petit
peu moins fringant que les autres donc
qu'il repasse adekeye qui va finir par
mourir de faim pour que les autres
puissent survivre
je pense que nos études ankama ce qu'ils
ont fait ce qu'elles ont
fait prendre conscience que voulait
peut-être pas décider tout de suite le
bti avait pas d'impact
norberg baker grand spécialiste du p tit
conteste les résultats de brigitte
poulin bd de land of the big o nous
avons mené de nombreuses études car il
est important de montrer que le bti n'a
pas d'impact mesurable sur la
biodiversité et sur la chaîne
alimentaire
il assure que lorsqu'il est bien
appliqué le betty n'a pas d'impact sur
les chironomes selon lui la manière dont
la lutte contre les moustiques est menée
dans la vallée du rhin n'a montré aucun
effet direct ou indirect sur l'abondance
des insectes aériens
il assure qu'il n'y aurait pas non plus
d'effets négatifs sur les oiseaux en
allemagne l'europe le coeur est très
critique envers le travail de brigitte
poulin et il dénonce en particulier sa
méthodologie
j'étais content cheikh près n'a pas
vérifié le nombre d'insectes avant le
traitement bd uniquement comparer de
gens l'une avec betty et notre sang
betty mais ne connaissez pas la quantité
exacte d'insectes présent avant le
traitement est racontée uniquement les
oisillons d'hirondelles suite sa
recherche a été faite après l'épandage
du bti donc à mon avis son étude n'a
aucune valeur scientifique
fx
mais cet avis n'est pas partagé par tous
brigitte poulin a permis de pointer du
doigt une cause potentielle du bti ou en
tout cas de la démoustication sur des
modifications dans l'intégralité de la
chaîne trophique donc de la chaîne
alimentaire donc d'un écosystème à
différents niveaux de différents
prédateurs etc
ça met en lumière quelque chose qui
jusqu'ici on pensait pas possible est ce
que c'est un cas particulier
est-ce que c'est généralisable dans
quelles conditions c'est là où justement
des travaux commencent à se mettre en
place par d'autres groupes de chercheurs
différend lié peut-être mais en tout cas
cette nuit là sur la je pense qu'elle
est importante
c'est dans ce laboratoire à ciel ouvert
que depuis plus d'une décennie
le scientifique carsten ball étudie les
effets de différents pesticides
chimiques sur les insectes et les
amphibiens
aujourd'hui il s'intéresse aux bété dans
ces bassins artificiels
il y mène une série d'expériences sur la
croissance de certaines espèces
nous allons traiter la moitié de ces
étangs avec du bti tandis que l'autre
moitié ne le sera pas nous regarderons
ensuite comment cela affecte le réseau
trophique comment les infirmiers les
libellules émergent de ses états quand
il le faut et dans quel état ils en
sortent et matis plus ou moins selon que
le bassin a été traitée ou non dans une
récente étude
carsten ball a découvert que le bêti
réduit la densité des larves de
moustiques de 98 % et celle des
chironomes émergents de plus de 50% des
résultats semblables à ceux de brigitte
couleurs nous réalisons si recherche
parce que le bti a des effets sur les
chironomes et les moustiques disent tous
ces deux groupes d'insectes constituent
la majorité de la biomasse dans les
systèmes aquatiques donc tout repose
vraiment sur ces deux groupes
alors on pense qu'en éliminant ces
groupes étudiants essentiellement avec
du bti le réseau trophique s'en trouvera
affecté match et se fait mais ce qui
fait la particularité des études de
carsten ball
c'est ce qu'ils viennent découvrir à
propos de l'effet du pt sur les
amphibiens en particulier la grenouille
rousse et le triton palmé
dans un bassin d'eau traitée au betty
l'équipe de carsten ball a constaté que
les larves de triton avait moins accès
aux larves de chironomes et de
moustiques en raison de cette diminution
importante de nourriture les tritons
lorsqu'ils sortent enfin de l'eau sont
plus petits que la normale pour carsten
ball le bêti aurait donc des
conséquences sur l'évolution des tritons
palmés sol donc on peut croire que ça
aura un impact sur leur performance au
moment où il passe sur la terre ferme
mais il ya plus le chercheur a aussi
analysé l'évolution de têtards de
grenouilles rousses exposé au betty les
résultats sont étonnants
contrairement des têtards évoluant dans
un environnement sans betty sur
l'expérience montre des signes de stress
oxydant ce stress oxydant entraîne un
vieillissement prématuré des cellules de
la grenouille contrairement à ce qu'on
croyait jusqu'à maintenant ces études
suggèrent que le bti aurait un impact
direct sur les vertébrés
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
examiné les faits direct du bpi
nous avons constaté qu'il ya une
indication de stress oxydant d'haydn
taille donc les grenouilles ne meurt pas
ce qui est une bonne chose mais leur
physiologie son trouve déréglé elles
sont stressées
à 40 km de la station de recherche de
carsten ball le spécialiste de mondial
du bti norberg becker ne partage pas cet
avis selon moi le stress vient d'une
température inadéquate lors de
l'expérience en laboratoire et non pas
du pire mais le mettez y ne cause pas de
stress sur les chronos
depuis 40 ans le professeur baker est de
tous les combats pour défendre le betty
il n'est pas du tout ébranlé par les
nouvelles études pour certains cette
confiance soulève des questions sur
l'éthique des recherches scientifiques
km après la pause dans la recherche
s'allie à l'industrie
[Musique]
en allemagne depuis 40 ans la
démoustication aux bêtises s'étend sur
un territoire de 300 kilomètres le long
du rhin
une région où habitent trois millions de
citoyens
c'est également dans cette région dans
ce complexe de chp ailleurs qu'on a
conduit de nombreuses études favorables
au betty ici loge l'association
allemande de contrôle des moustiques
le câble et trois groupes de recherche
voué à la démoustication quatre
institutions tout dirigé jusqu'à
récemment par norbert baker à quelques
pas du complexe on retrouve un imposant
bâtiment rempli de betty c'est là que
nous amène le biologiste norberg baker
nous fait d'abord visité un entrepôt
réfrigéré à l'intérieur des centaines de
bach le granules gelé à base de bti
aussi les granules glace et c'est ici
que sont produites ces granules destiné
à l'épandage aériennes de la compagnie
haïti bac où nous produisons et gagnent
une classe il voici l'ingrédient actif
nous mélangeons le betty avec de l'eau
et ensuite nous le plaçons dans de la
zot pour le geler une méthode inventé et
breveté par norbert baker un peu plus
loin le biologiste nous fait visiter une
autre section de l'immeuble une centaine
de bari de betty purent y sont
entreposés nous utilisons ce produit
avec thomas wg le bti arrive sous forme
de poudre que nous importons de la
compagnie valence biosciences aux états
unis
la société valenza n 6 a été fondée en
2000 par le géant japonais sumitomo
chemical
c'est dans son usine de l'iowa que
valent une paille osseuse fabrique ses
nombreux billets aux insecticides dont
le bti qu'elle vend partout sur la
planète
ce responsable technique de verlaine
bioscience aux vents du bti sur internet
il propose aussi des outils pour
répandre le larvicide avec norbert de
bakker people de chant à rédiger deux
études qui démontrent l'efficacité du
bti ces articles ont été publiés dans la
revue scientifique de l'association
américaine de contrôle des moustiques un
organisme commandité par plusieurs
entreprises de démoustication donc
valence bioscience pendant près de 40
ans norberg baker s'est associé à la
grande industrie tant pour le
financement de ces travaux de chercheurs
et ceux de ces étudiants que pour la
diffusion de la connaissance entourant
le bti arrive non je n'ai aucun problème
à coopérer avec cette industrie c'est
mon besoin d'elle notamment pour savoir
comment bien appliqué le bdi la fois
scientifique consiste à définir les
bases de l'application du produit pour
montrer que ce n'est pas nocif pour
l'environnement
et c'est ce qui a été fait ici depuis
trente ou quarante ans norman baker a
aussi fondé une société commerciale
culine ex baker qui l'a présidée pendant
27 ans cette entreprise vend des
comprimés de bti produits grâce à un
procédé qu'il a lui-même profité
kleenex baker distribue aussi trois
billes aux insecticides de valencians
mon revenu ne dépend pas de cette
activité
c'est important comme certains pensaient
que je gagnais beaucoup d'argent avec
culine ex j'ai arrêté ses activités
commerciales et les ai confié monfils et
crevettes ou mason pour certains
chercheurs
la proximité de norbourg becker avec
l'industrie du bti soulève des questions
éthiques
yves si ceux qui vendent un produit dit
aussi que c'est absolument sécuritaire
est enfourné c'est sans danger pour
l'environnement et bon marché
c'est donc parfait acheté le mois vous
savez on devrait avoir un contrôle
indépendant sur ses déclarations
les organismes qui sont en charge du
contrôle des moustiques ce qu'il faut ça
s'apparente plus à de la religion où on
décide en fait de la réponse on n'essaie
pas de questions on essaie de la réponse
on dit par exemple betty n'a pas
d'impact et après on a celle de
démontrer
norberg becker se défend bien d'être
partial
quand on lui pose la question sur son
indépendance scientifique
sa réponse est claire obs nos ds might
think so lu ment oui mon âme de
scientifiques vie pour le bêti je ne
devrais pas dire ça mais je crois cet
organisme fait partie de la nature et
peut contribuer à résoudre des problèmes
qui nuisent aux êtres humains human
being alors je ne vois pas de problème à
ce que vers l'inde ou d'autres
organisations similaires nous soutient
dans ce contexte carsten ball et
brigitte poulet ne s'étonne pas que
leurs travaux est été remis en question
par norbert baker alors qu'il était le
directeur scientifique de l'association
allemande de contrôle des moustiques et
le président de l'association mondiale
de contrôle des moustiques
baker est préoccupé par le contrôle des
moustiques ces études portent sur la
meilleure façon de les tuer c'est sa
spécialité comment se débarrasser des
moustiques champs d'intérêt est
totalement différent je regarde comment
les écosystèmes sont affectés lorsqu'on
élimine tous les moustiques et d'autres
organismes
c'est une approche assez différentes
ce conflit entre les deux chercheurs a
pris une tournure inattendue lorsque
carsten ball a reçu une mise en demeure
de l'association allemande de contrôle
des moustiques
le groupe de norbert joker lui reproche
de dire publiquement que l'épandage de
betty en allemagne se fait sans tenir
compte de l'impact sur les chironomes je
les ai vus à la télé nous avons
l'enregistrement et nous avons engagé à
l'avocat carsten ball répond que c'est
sa liberté d'opinion que tout le monde
peut dire ce qu'il veut mais c'était
toujours à mon avis un mensonge nous
travaillons pour conserver la
biodiversité et maintenant ils nous
blâmer prétend que nous tuons la
nourriture des chauves souris et des
oiseaux
ce n'est tout simplement pas vrai nous
avons donc agi comme ça pour que ça
cesse
[Musique]
la meilleure réponse à la science et la
science et qu'on arrive sur le domaine
de la politique c'est à dire qu'on va
commencer à faire du juridique ou à
attaquer on va dire le travail ou la
personne
là on est sur l'affectif et l'affectif
c'est pas comme ça qu'on réponde la
suite
malgré cette mise en demeure
carsten ball va poursuivre ses
recherches j'ai l'habitude de travailler
sur les pesticides et dans ce domaine
cette façon de faire est très courante
par exemple lorsque chercheurs publics
litra that joue un rôle dans le
développement de cancers
immédiatement il y à une étude qui
proviennent l'industrie qui dit que
c'est de la foutaise
c'est exactement ce qui se passe ici
l'objectif est de jeter un doute sur la
science nos travaux ne seraient pas bons
on travaille dans de petites universités
nous ne sommes pas de véritables
scientifiques nous sommes des mantas
douze brigitte poulin et doudi fait ça
avec brigitte poulin et aussi avec moi
résultat il n'ya presque plus de
scientifiques qui veulent aborder la
question du bti parce que c'est un sujet
très très délicat où les scientifiques
nous sommes habituellement pas
confrontés à ce genre de situation
alors qu'en europe et scientifique
s'affrontent sur l'impact du pays
au québec sept ans je commence à
mobiliser les citoyens qui demandent
plus de transparence sur l'utilisation
de ce larvicide après la pause stopper
le bti
[Musique]
des citoyens des laurentides en forme et
un regroupement qui s'opposent aux bété
il désapprouve la décision prise par
leurs élus dépendre cela revisite sur le
territoire de la municipalité
pour une petite municipalité comme la
belle avec 2000 quelques habitants
d'avoir un budget de 650 mille dollars
pour l'épandage de bti sur trois années
c'est énorme
on s'est mis à faire des petites
recherches pour trouver que c'était on
monte pas une bonne idée de faire ça
donc on s'est fait un comité qu'on a
commencé à vérifier qu est-ce qui est un
scientifique mans à lire tout cela c'est
dans ce contexte que la chercheuse
brigitte poulin a été invité à la belle
à l'été 2010 9 pour y présenter le
résultat de ses recherches
les dvd parce qu'elle consomme beaucoup
nous c'est que d'aucuns nomment que
j'attrape dans leur trou et ligne arié
pi et françois labelle espère que cette
conférence permettra d'amorcer un
véritable débat sur l'utilisation du
betty et la recherche de solutions
alternatives
source europe 1 le but c'est de prendre
soin de notre environnement de
t'informer d'être bien informés plus
dire qu'est ce qui est mieux pour chez
nous c'est vraiment de faire une
réflexion sur le bétail
ah la belle c'est la compagnie gdg
environnement qui a obtenu le contrat de
démoustication cette entreprise de
trois-rivières s'occupe de la
distribution et de l'épandage du bio
insecticides de vérone bioscience dans
l'est du pays
le bti est un produit homologué au
canada où on utilise depuis près de 40
ans chaque année gdg et pense larvicide
sur le territoire d'une cinquantaine de
municipalités où vivent près de deux
millions d'habitants
attention le mot confort et je n'aime
pas tellement c'est parce qu'on fait une
association que le confort et le luxe et
des municipalités où on travaille c'est
pas un luxe mais drôlement pour ce grand
qualité de vie
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs années le président du
développement des affaires chez gdg
explique les bienfaits du bti sur
différentes tribunes mais le message de
gdg passe de plus en plus difficilement
en plus de la belle des groupes de
citoyens se sont formés un peu partout
au québec pour contester l'épandage au
bti près de chez eux
enfin
[Musique]
en
lors d'une séance d'information à
rivière-rouge plusieurs citoyens se sont
opposées à l'octroi de contrats à g des
jo ils sont inquiets pour la
biodiversité dans la salle la tension
est palpable
la représentante de la municipalité
tente de calmer les opposants qui team
nous a causé des blessures qui était de
biologistes qui venait selon richard
vadeboncoeur seul gdg est habilité à
parler de contrôle des insectes picardie
pour convaincre les citoyens de la
pertinence du pays
ils s'étaient étude du chercheur
allemand norbert baker jeudi midi mais à
long terme
on parle d'un prix de centaines de
publications scientifiques et zéro dégât
rapporté
ces arguments n'ont pas suffi à
convaincre les citoyens de rivière rouge
qui ont finalement rejeté l'utilisation
du bti sur leur territoire
c'est facile de le dire sont au vert
conseil municipal les dimensions on en
veut où on n'avait pas donc l
accessibilité là dedans c'est triste
mais je pense que les gens frappent la
mauvaise cible simplement parce que
c'est accessible ces gens à losc a lancé
son strict sur un cdd bompard parole
d'attac bien que moi et devrait taper
sur le clou mais comme on dit dans le
bas saint laurent une petite
municipalité a décidé de se passer du
betty
à saint-andré-de-kamouraska les eaux
stagnantes au bord du fleuve sont un
formidable incubateur pour les
moustiques
un problème qui handicape depuis
longtemps la communauté
c'est invivable à cause du nombre de
moustiques qui nous tournait autour de
latin est à toute heure du jour
remarcher l'extérieur et qui est obligé
de constamment balayé la tête pas
capable de tenir des activités
culturelles à l'extérieur pour qu'elle
va de manger à l'extérieur prend le
petit repos le soir ça va être serré
après avoir songé à utiliser le bti la
municipalité a décidé d'agir autrement
et avait vraiment une question
financière qui avait une question
écologique ou si on ne voulait pas
intervenir là où les moustiques ont
leurs lieux pompe naturellement on
voulait intervenir que là où il y avait
des habitations
en 2017 les citoyens ont choisi une
stratégie en quatre temps
premièrement ils ont commencé par
éliminer les nids de pompes des
moustiques sur leur terrain et dans les
gouttières
puis ils ont posé des nichoirs pour les
oiseaux insectivores comme les
hirondelles et des cabanes à chauves
souris
ensuite ils ont placé des plantes
répulsives à proximité des aires de vie
extérieur
enfin la municipalité s'est tourné vers
une technologie récente en faisant
l'acquisition de bornes anti moustiques
ces pièges de conception française sont
inspirés des travaux de brigitte poulet
en camargue on s'était peut-être que
comme ça en mettant plusieurs pièges qui
font vraiment une ceinture autour d'une
zone habitée on pourrait arriver à
réduire les nuisances avec une
efficacité comparable à celle du bti qui
est pas efficace à 100 % ce qui est
plutôt efficace de l'ordre de 80 % et à
fès est ce que c'est ce qu'on a aussi
observé avec sa trentaine de bornes anti
moustiques saint-andré-de-kamouraska est
le seul endroit en amérique du nord où
l'on retrouve ce type de piège
le mandat de s'occuper de la gestion des
pièges a été confiée à francine côté et
jacques baudat des mois de mai à
septembre
il veille à la bonne marche des
opérations les bornes anti moustiques
possède un rayon d'action de 60 mètres
elles sont situées à 120 mètres l'une de
l'autre les pièges sont placés tout
autour du village afin de créer une
ceinture de protection contre les
moustiques démarrait au nord et ceux des
terres agricoles au sud
[Musique]
chaque semaine jacques bodart fait le
tour du village pour l'entretien des
bornes
il débute la maintenance en changeant
les leurs effectifs et les bouteilles de
co2 recycler le co2 il imite la
respiration humaine donc le co2 dans
l'ohio d'action pour attirer les
moustiques et pour confirmer qu'il ya
quelque chose à piquer il sait on à de
l'acide lactique l'acide lactique lui il
imite la transpiration humain puis il
remplace les 5
les moustiques viennent là dedans ils
sont aspirés par le ventilateur vient de
se coincer dans le filet et avec le
passage de l'air il sèche ça fonctionne
pour les clients cela fonctionne pas
c'est ça fonctionne pas et je détestais
moi même
ok aucunement les moustiques pointe et
de syrie par le piège mais rendu près du
piège - les verts végétaux avec une
moyenne 2 millions de moustiques capturé
par année à saint-andré-de-kamouraska
est ce suffisant pour assurer une
meilleure qualité de vie aux résidants
on sait qu'un euro toujours mais sont en
vie avait tu sais courait que le met en
doute tellement moins maintenant
beaucoup moins
le maire qui possède aussi un piège ne
regrette pas d'avoir privilégié les
méthodes alternatives au bti ça donne
pas des résultants aussi flamboyant mais
notre population est très à l'aise avec
le fait qu' on n'a pas éliminer
complètement les mots c'est qu'ils ont
droit de vivre aussi chez eux
au québec les municipalités qui optent
pour le bti doivent obtenir un
certificat d'autorisation
c'est le ministère de l'environnement
qui l'attribuent après avoir consulté le
ministère de la faune nous avons appris
que le ministère de la faune met la
touche finale à une revue détaillée des
études scientifiques sur le bti
certaines de ces conclusions se retrouve
déjà dans un document interne
d'orientation dont nous avons obtenu
copie
ce document est destiné aux
fonctionnaires du ministère qui analyse
les demandes d'épandage du larvicide on
y apprend que le ministère de la faune
s'inquiète des effets directs et
indirects du bti en s'appuyant entre
autres sur les études de brigitte poulin
et de carsten ball aucune étude de
norbert becker n'est mentionnée pour
éviter tout risque de dommages graves ou
irréversibles à l'environnement
le ministère recommande d'appliquer le
principe de précaution
il recommande aussi l'utilisation de
méthodes alternatives comme celle des
pièges à moustiques
le débat autour du betty ne fait que
commencer
chez nous et à l'étranger bien des
questions restent en suspens des
questions auxquelles il faudra tout à
trouver des réponses
[Musique]
est ce qu'on doit utiliser de bti
peut-être mais surtout est-ce qu'on doit
traiter les populations d'insectes est
ce qu'on doit continuer à les traiter de
manière aussi intense est ce qu'on doit
changer d'alternative
est ce qu'on doit changer la mentalité
avec laquelle on appréhende le problème
moustiques donc il ya toute une campagne
de réappropriation de la place des
insectes dans notre monde et de notre
place avec eux et notre interaction
tournant après la pause comment mieux
assurer notre autonomie alimentaire un
aperçu
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine à l'émission la
crise qu'on vit actuellement exposé
certaines failles de la mondialisation
quand tous les masques par exemple sont
produits à l'étranger
ça nous rend vulnérable mais qu'en est
il de notre production alimentaire
sommes-nous au tout suffisant est ce que
notre agriculture pourrait être plus
résiliente un grand dossier à la semaine
verte à l'ange-gardien en outaouais
françois biron est l'un des rares
producteurs maraîchers à faire pousser
des légumes en plein hiver
comme je peux pas inventer de légumes la
seule chose que je peux faire des
différents des autres c'est d'avoir des
légumes quand les autres en ont pas ce
que permet les serres froides ces
épinards sont qu'elle et ses autres
légumes feuilles pousse dans des serres
qui ne sont pas chauffées mais l'auto
suffisance est encore loin à peine le
tiers des légumes de serre consommés au
québec ont poussé dans la province
voilà c'est tout pour cette émission au
nom de toute l'équipe merci de nous
suivre si fidèlement et bonne semaine
verte